what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a second
trailer for TMNT mutant Mayhem joined of
course by our Ninja Turtles expert our
Aficionado guys I'm telling you he knows
everything about Ninja Turtles if he
gets anything wrong shocker make sure to
rip him apart in the comments because he
knows everything I can attest John is an
expert you ready to bring your A game
today
don't let us down every piece of
knowledge he knows it all guys wanted to
be a a Cowabunga and leave a like is
that how they say it John that is not
exactly how they say it but it's a
warning man it's okay
somehow I'm not you you're like halfway
there I'm not you it's okay you will be
at the end of this trailer well you're
gonna shred this commentary let's go
there Jackie Chan we're just running
errands that's it
there's some of the guys wanted to get
pizza and I tried to talk him out of it
monsters that were shunned by society
and we could do what we wanted what
would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
it's insane
team I want to know everything about you
our dad is definitely not a giant rat
that makes me feel like he's a rap
police are back I like video April
crimewave led by a Superfly
why because he kills everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool
and then everyone will think we're cool
they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
damn got some little tortoises huh I
can't believe there are other mutants
so we're gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth or reverses peoples they got to go
um
we gotta try all right six in the
morning police at my dog
[Music]
my son Michelangelo you have heart
s Donatello you have wisdom
you have bravery and rage
I dream about fighting every night
You've Got A Rage that's not a problem
wow
do I looking massive yeah
oh this looks so fun
wow
wow yeah loved it absolutely loved it
especially after watching across the
spider verse there's a sucker for this
kind of animation and all those like
details to the motion but John please
our expert at all costs break it down
for you know what no nay I'm gonna go to
the character line up here of our mutant
villains yeah and John you bet you gotta
nail down everyone every single one out
research you better you better get this
okay better get this I see obviously
there's Bebop and Rocksteady flanking
Superfly still not 100 sure of Superfly
and Baxter Stockman are gonna be in any
way related to one another uh we also
got I think Ray filet with the uh the
little scuba gear on and uh okay by post
Malone played by post Malone and then um
it looks like that looks like a a gecko
gecko yeah yeah yeah who is Gordon Gekko
no no
I know everything yes I'll give you a
hint there's like an art style uh a
famous art style for like come on this
is an odd Hint it begins with the letter
M as in mother there you go oh you sure
like a mod like Mondo the company yeah I
get you yeah Mondo Gekko back there and
and the bat as well uh who is called I
don't know let's get nuts hey it's not
Batman it's not Michael no it's like a
Batman parody character come on yeah
let's get no I'm giving you a hint here
nut head
nutty bat come on uh my favorite martial
arts style is wing wing nuts there you
go oh my God you did it my expert oh
dude and I didn't need any help or
guidance or clues or anything oh I don't
know who that is in the bottom left the
Genghis frog over here probably
I'm sorry
oh there's a couple of his other
amphibious cohorts we got through them
all somehow did we I mean we don't
there's no leather head in here I mean
Leatherhead kind of flips back and forth
in terms of uh Pro or antagonist Ally or
Foe yeah
um but yeah it's a Rogues gallery
they're a league they're a team they're
a unit I'm loving it at all costs yes
absolutely yeah no this was a beautiful
trailer that was really capturing the
spirit of the turtles all around
um I even love the like old school
animation style when they are
fantasizing with what looks like the
Monopoly man awarding them an
opportunity to be accepted by Uncle
Moneybags is it public oh and yeah and
Jackie Chan got more lines in here in
this one trailer than he did in the
entire Kung Fu Panda franchise yes isn't
that crazy guy totally
add more I mean I I
this is this is lovely I mean this looks
like the perfect blend of things because
like there I like that they're not
giving you too much but they are hinting
at like oh yeah we're gonna get all
these characters from across the turtle
verse together
um but while still maintaining this
really lovely just sort of Brotherly
camaraderie between all of them both
these trailers have centered on that and
I think that's a smart thing plus now we
know that Master Splinter takes offense
to the use of the word rat in a
derogatory fashion which is uh you know
a good humans to that if you call
someone a rat yeah you say someone looks
like a rat that's right they take they
take offense to that yeah it's it's
social commentary and that's what we
come to Ninja Turtles for foremost and
uh yeah I thought the whole thing with
with these teenagers really wanting
nothing more than just to be regular
teenagers it feels like it's going to be
a another great comic-based story about
acceptance that no you guys are not
normal teenagers but that's okay because
you have something in you that is unique
and special and don't worry all you guys
will get to date April O'Neil one day
each one of you at the same time it'll
just be it's a new time now that we live
in all right they're going to be poly
it'll be great yeah it looks amazing
perfect uh no this looks absolutely
beautiful and I can't wait to watch this
in the in the cinemas yeah I think this
might be one we actively go to the
theaters for John it's give and take
sometimes we go to theaters and
sometimes we just buy them even though
people say you're not supporting the
movies by reacting them here when we
literally buy the home we purchase the
whole movie so we are literally helping
their bottom line at a crucial second
wave of sales
I mean yes opening night is important
with the DVD sales the streaming sales
also important yeah they all social rely
on that very very much people are
striking for those earnings right now
and how they should be allocated
um alrighty guys well thank you so much
for being here
um much love to all of you and hopefully
we watch the right trailer if you get my
drift because this might have come out a
little bit early without people no not
everyone getting a chance to see it
early that would be the crime of the
century not even four turtles could
could solve that problem
yeah there's a good place
Ryan Styles Smith Kevin Smith Meek
Adrian Brody Tims real John campia's
favorite word
Heather Richard Gere Ian McKellen Simon
Songhai Crispin Glover Kayla Davis the
king look it up
that's a real person
Alan Alda Ling Logan Lerman burden Kiera
Kiara nightly Eric benetcons 39 Karen
kusiama director still count Nick Frost
X Dijon January Jones Don Juan DeMarco
Longoria Cliff Curtis Robert Rodriguez
Master iced tea I guess Denzel goat
Nation who's the greatest of all time
Lorenzo Baxter burgundy his dog
differently Shania Twain Marco Polo
Tunstall Lauren America Ferreira horse
simply Tom faded Sawyer Sarah Jessica 94
Kerr Justin Timberlake Martin Rosie
O'Donnell uh uh which is the baby you
know Warren Beatty there you go Colin
mockery Philip Justice Smith Jr Jen
Aniston Smith
Melanie Matt LeBlanc
you've never heard that ever any of you
guys that took us eight minutes to film
believe it or not it's your inspiration
let's try this full name the best names
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for being here I hope you have a
wonderful summer
and hope to see you back here in fall
and winter and next spring peace out
Rejects
[Music]